hello and welcome to our webinar
career webinar on job search in the
world of ai
recruitment secrets and resume tips
revealed for 2021
and our guest today is nikunj varma the
ceo and co-founder of cut short
a little bit more about him in a moment
first i'd like to
[Music]
give you a few tips about how to use
webex
while we're in this session the q a
button with the question mark
allows you to send a question to us
for new clinch to address in the q a
portion of the
webinar at the end and
remember to hit all panelists and hit
send
similarly with chat you can send us
messages do
use all panelists or host and presenter
and we'll see that and hit send
and we're also going to be doing
a poll during the webinar let's
start off with a pre-poll just to see
how that goes very simple
what is your current job role
and how are you feeling today we like to
ask that second question
because of the stresses of
the current global pandemic
i want to check in with everyone and see
how you're doing
and that's just a simple thumbs up
thumbs down
kind of reading
leave the poll open for about another 30
seconds
and please do remember to hit submit
and we'll close in five four
three two
one
and here are our poll results
so i think
we have a number of students and a
number of people outside of
listed tech jobs i think this will be
very interesting for
all of you today so let me introduce
nikon
and he is the ceo and co-founder of cut
short
which is india's go-to hiring platform
for companies hiring quality talent
um he has in the past worked at
carbonite and zamanda
and he has an mba from xlri
uh and be in computer science from uit
rgpv so welcome nikunj
and i'm going to stop sharing my screen
and allow you to share yours
okay thank you thanks stuart thanks
everyone
for joining this webinar today i hope
i'm audible
yes you are okay
okay so let me start my screen sharing
in the meantime uh i think stewart gave
some introduction about me i'm not sure
how many have you
up you have heard about cutshot but
increasingly you will hear more about it
if you have not
if you have used it if you have already
know about good shots great give us
feedback
uh as stuart said cut short is the
india's go to hiring platform it's
becoming one of the most popular ones
out there
the conventional job portals are you
know going out of favor so
uh platform like cut short which is
which are more built
holistically around the entire hiring
hiring problem and career problem is
something that is
uh you know getting more and more
adoption right now
so let me share my screen and
i hope you guys can see my screen yep
okay so poll is pretty interesting
stuart i think uh
it's really a very diverse crowd right
now here
in this webinar right so uh feel free
you guys to you know to ask questions if
something is not relevant to you
i'll try to keep the content more
broader rather than
specific to a specific audience uh but
if you need more context then feel free
to put it in the q a section
that we can pick up those questions so
in the session or maybe
outside of the session or towards the
end of the session as well
uh i just uh you know jotted down a few
points
so you know it's mostly a mapping of
what
my current state of mind is about what
do i think about you know the career
of the progression the career
or context right now uh this year
2020 as you know has been sort of a
nightmare
for most of the people in the industry
uh so you know it's a very special
timing for us to
be talking about this topic uh when it
is december
uh and the year is going to end so i'll
just
uh you know share some of the points
that i noted and then
let's do it more interactively or
towards the end of the webinar where you
can ask more questions that are relevant
to you
does that sound okay so it yes it does
okay all right you have to go right
ahead
we're going to start with uh what the
present recruitment trends are
can you tell us more about that
you i miss your question a little but i
assume that you're asking about
uh how is our situation of hiring and
what is the trend right now is that a
question that's correct yeah present
recruitment trends
yeah so as i said this is a pretty
special time for us to be talking about
this topic
so this is a graph that i pulled from
cut short itself this is
our uh employer activity on the question
platform
as you can see in january uh and then it
you know in january everything was kind
of okay we were coming
uh from december of you know peaceful
year
or peaceful month of that last year and
then generally everything was fine then
feb
4 would start happening march it became
you know more and more
into the it got into the public uh
conscience a bit more
and marches when the lockdown started
happening especially in india
uh and then you can see that april may
june these are two or three years
two or three months where things were
pretty subdued uh
activity started happening because this
as i said this data is mostly from cut
shots so
uh you know we were going this year we
have grown more
but uh you know you can see that the
trend or the growth has been
uh in like in in april march april may
time frame it has been slow and then
suddenly it has picked up
and you can see in october it has really
picked up from the september time frame
and november also it is pretty much
going strong so
uh this is as i said this is cut short
data so
as an industry uh the the
you know the transitions would not have
been so sharp
but uh this is the kind of trend that
you will see even if you look at the
popular
industry trend that uh every uh
in march april june july time frame
everything was really
really going bad uh and then started
picking up
and in october november time frame or
everyone started
reporting more hiring more jobs opening
up more companies coming out of their
uh exile and hiring freezes so this is
basically
at that time when uh cobia happened in
june timeframe when we started
uh calling the companies that what were
they doing this is what they told us
that
25 companies said no we are laying off
employees and we are no longer hiring
it's completely completely a disaster
for us uh at the same time 45
companies who were not directly impacted
because of the
uh weight situation but they also went
in a hiring breeze because
uh they were sort of playing
conservative they were not sure what
will happen
so 45 companies although were not
impacted directly
or they were not in the bad sectors
which got affected like travel
or entertainment or you know on sports
and all those things they were not there
but
they stopped their hiring or and they
took a break
and then there were a lot of companies
that were hiring as well like this md
and those were the
beneficiaries in some ways of uh the
covered impact
uh so this is what it was and uh as
expected
uh as two zero two one we are going to
enter two zero two one
we're also seeing a big update of big
positive news coming on the vaccine
front
and even without vaccines i think people
were generally getting more used to the
entire scenario with coveted around us
and now you know we expect a big rebound
to happen
as you can see in november december the
numbers are anyway
looking up uh pretty steeply up from the
previous months
and we expect that in 2021 all those
companies 45
companies that pause their hiring
although they were not impacted
now they will come back to the market so
there will be a lot of pent-up demand
from the industry uh coming into zero to
one and with vaccine and other political
news
we believe that uh in 2021 uh it will be
actually a bigger
much bigger one than even two zero to
one nine two zero one eight
uh and it will continue to have that
momentum uh at least into zero to one so
it's so that's a good news
for all of us uh and i think before we
go further
it looks like kobe was you know a big uh
uh you know great let down everybody got
impacted
but uh just to you know to have a real
sense of realism here uh what we also
see that there has been a major demand
for skilled professionals even during
the pandemic
so that is something that we all hear in
this room uh when we have the
the tools to understand in a larger
context in a global context
uh and we are all knowledge workers in
some ways so we are more privileged than
errors
and we see that even during pandemic
there was a big demand for skilled
professionals so
it's not like everyone was out of job a
lot of skilled professionals
was uh was still in demand they were
still making getting salary hikes and
everything else so
not everything was bad for everyone else
the biggest impact
happened in non-residential and support
functions right wherever there was no
uh there was no need for people to have
more labor intensive functions and
support functions or hr functions
or you know field operations or some
other
stuff that was no longer required uh and
those were the hardest
job functions and while domain
exhaustive professionals uh
who really did not have a very dominant
specific uh
uh skill set like they were not like air
hostesses or they're not like
waiters uh they were the people who had
more cross-functional cross domain skill
set
they could even if they got affected
they were able to shift to
the other sectors which were not
affected or which were booming in some
ways
so the the the pandemic was bad news but
there were some people who were not
really so much badly impacted and what
do we learn
since we're talking about careers here
uh and we're gonna talk about
you know how to build a career and you
know how to grow
and how to plan things around our career
i think uh which is what is the most
important thing before i move on from
this
pandemic situation or pandemic
expression is that
there are some lessons here for all of
us in this room
and the lesson is very clear uh if you
even if the
in the worst of the worst times if you
have certain things right
then you have a better shot in really
withstanding all these
you know crisis kind of situations that
people of the time will throw at you
and what are those lessons that you know
i was thinking about those lessons and i
realized that
or these are some lessons that came to
my mind the first one is
be the best you can be in your chosen
work area right a lot of people
uh don't choose their work area properly
or they are not passionate about it
right so i think the first
most important thing is if you uh if
you've chosen a work area strategically
and you want to you should be upskilling
yourself to become the best in that area
if you are the best no matter what what
is happening in the in the industry
there will always be a demand for you
domain knowledge is good
but try to work across my domains a lot
of people i see in the earlier
stages of their career they get into a
company or in a specific industry and
then they start picking up a domain
expertise
and they spend 5 years 10 years 15 years
in the same domain
although that's great but you will find
that beyond a specific time for very
specific for a very
specific set of people that much domain
understanding going into deep
one domain really does not help you it
actually makes things more risky so try
to
get more cross-functional cross-domain
experience uh
as a profession that's always good to
have so that's one more lesson from the
pandemic
third is uh try to work in a profit
center or not cost center
or anything which is uh an operational
work which is
measured in by the number of hours you
spend on it those are the things that
typically get impacted more because
people shift their budgets from you know
they reduce the
the call centers the reduce uh the
people who are in the front line
handling people uh they reduce the
people who are in the financial
uh you know who are in some kind of low
level financial work
remove all of that so try to be in the
profit center
uh where your work directly results in
some kind of revenue
uh and like software is a great example
of that uh
where the software is something which
you write today and it will keep on
you know getting sold again and again
without you having to work occasionally
for it so try to work in something which
is more
aligned with the revenue and not so much
in terms of the cost
uh and again something which is to do
more with the impact rather than
something to do with more number of
hours you spend on it
so that's again one more lesson that we
can
learn uh then this is again the same
point that
uh choose the profession where your
impact is measured
in numbers in matrix and not in terms of
hours
uh the other thing from the pandemic
that we saw
in terms of major layoffs that happen or
numbers of years of experience right and
uh this is something as a modern
professional
all of us we need to understand this
that uh
our years of experience in the in the
yesteryears uh
it grew linearly uh and along with it
your salary your position your job
security everything kind of grew
linearly
but that is no longer any true anymore
because now we are seeing that
just by having more number of years on
the resume you are no
you know you're no more valuable than
anybody else who has less
less years of experience so that is
something which is a big
thing that pandemic has told because uh
in the pandemic time when the bad
situation or bad times happened the
first ones
that were you know that were laid off
were the people who
had who were the highest lb range uh who
had more years of experience but who are
not really so much valuable to the
business
immediately so uh it's all
so number of years is only an asset and
it can be a big asset by the way i'm not
saying that
the more number of years you have on
your resume is not good it's great in
fact
it is something which can really make
you uh much much much more valuable than
anybody else out there
but it only works if your if those
experience those years
uh they actually have told you something
that you have taught something to you
you've learned something greatly in
those years and then that's when it
becomes then
then only it becomes an asset otherwise
becomes a liability
right so i'm seeing a lot of questions
coming in so i'll just stop after this
thing and
i'll just take the questions if they are
uh
relevant to this uh what i'm going
through or and we can take them in the
end so what can let me know if there are
questions that we can take right now
uh yeah right now um
i would like to ask one of the questions
was you showed a
growth chart um
global or india only
that was india only and then the data
came from cut short
and specific so yeah you need to just
adjust a bit uh for a global context of
local context but the trend
would remain the same the three the the
quarter quarter two of that year
was really bad everything went down and
the next two quarters it was like uh
going flat and then uh in
october november december time frame uh
things are 30 40 percent up so that is
how the trend will you will see across
any
major geography and the last thing
which uh coming back to what i'm
presenting so last thing which i wanted
to
really highlight here is you need to
plan for bad things
right these things will happen now i
think most of us
who are uh you know in our uh
you know early to late 20s or 30s we
have not seen that much of
you know world professional world
changing so much
that we sometimes were led into
believing that everything was going to
be constant i think
every year we would get a hike uh our
jobs will still be safe
uh and uh you know situations like
pandemic and
these kind of situations wouldn't happen
to us but you know if you look back
and see in the history these things have
happened before
it's just that in our uh limited amount
of you know time in on the planet we
have not seen that happening
so a lot of people were really caught up
by surprise uh
and the right time right in terms of a
financial planning in terms of skilling
planning
uh people ex thought everything would
work no the way it was working before
but then this pandemic has told us and
taught us that
things can happen bad uh and it is a law
of nature
so what we need to do is plan for the
bad things so in terms of
all the planning you need to account for
these things to happen
and if these things do happen then we
need to be resilient
we just can't be uh you know of
thinking like jumping up and down not
really thinking straight
or taking it too you know negatively you
have to look at it
and see the opportunity also in these
crisis and you will find a lot of
companies got
started in this time a lot of people uh
found time to upskill themselves because
uh this
opportunity or this pandemic gave them
the opportunity to think
to reboot themselves so these things
will happen and i think most important
thing is if you have planned things
better
then you will not be so so negatively
impacted
and in those cases you are better you
know positioned to create
or to make uh you know use of these
opportunities because everybody else
will be down
and you have the opportunity of really
creating something uh
when you know things are not looking up
for so many other people so that would
be a great chance for you to
uh make sense and you know make take
advantage of these things
uh any questions you have stuart then i
think
i'll just go to the job search or
inclusive one and beyond
the tips around that any question that
came in
i'm not sure if stuart can hear me yeah
i
i can't i'm sorry i was unmute i have a
question from the audience that relates
to what you were just saying
which is um this
individual personas saw that legacy
system
jobs survived more than new digital jobs
in their environment um is that
something you're seeing or
are you seeing something different okay
that's an interesting aspect of the
entire
situation right so there will be pockets
right where there will be
uh less demand and also less supply and
they would
be relatively you know shock proof
in some ways because they're so closed
they're so niche they're so
so legacy oriented or around legacy
topical skills that there's not enough
people in demand supply and you need
those many people to continue your
operation so there is no layoff
uh that's also an interesting point
but i think and i thought about this
point but i also realized that
as an as a modern worker uh
having getting into a legacy kind of a
place where
you are protected from the outside world
it's great but it also is
a liability because you're not getting
the benefit
of the industry you know growing outside
of english
or outside of a legacy so i think it's
important to be
in the place where there is more demand
and supply so there are more companies
that are hiring
and there are less number of talented
people still people available
that's one condition and second
condition is that you should also be
looking at the growth of that industry
so always align yourself with growth
right uh i think in terms of your career
protecting your career if you try to
protect it it is not going to work out
because something will disrupt it
legacy systems legacy technologies get
distracted all the time
right so and if that happens then you
will be really caught on the wrong foot
right so always look for uh ideally
where
there is less more demand less supply
less number of people
and also provision that also plan that
that sector that
role that you're trying to get into has
a really
aggressive growth curve and those are
two things if you do it right and play
it right then that's
that will work to your favor that's what
that leads into your next uh topic which
is
you know how to go about a job search in
2021
okay okay so job search in 2021 and
beyond right so
uh why i'm saying two zero to one and
not two zero two zero what changed right
so all of us know that a lot of stuff
changed
in 2020 and it changed for good uh
it changed for really long term uh and
sometimes these things happen
and you know they accelerate the entire
uh slow process that was happening in
the background and that's what happened
in this case
a lot of hiring fundamentals and job
search fundamentals are going to be the
same
right and like most things fundamentals
don't really change a lot
what changes often is the the
format of things right so you have
earlier you have different
sports version and now you have the new
sports version but the fundamentals of
cricket or any other game remain the
same
similar to that the job search context
is not changing or job search
fundamentals not changing
what is changing is how companies are
going to be hiring so kind of methods
they adopt
uh the kind of uh you know the so what
has happened is of the demand supply
changes that are happening
uh and how will they affect you and how
you can make a winning strategy for your
career move
into 0 to 1 and beyond so let me just uh
go through what i uh jotted down this
afternoon so as i i'll just again repeat
the same thing
or right do what you're passionate about
i think a lot of people
uh and i want to make i want to take a
bit of time before i go to tactical work
or tactical tips i don't know do this on
your resume do that on your resume
i just want to always start from the
basics i always want to start from the
fundamentals
uh i think if you take step uh the most
important step first which is the
fundamentals of everything and it makes
really makes it easy for you to
do that tactical part better so i think
again i would like to re-emphasize
a lot of people in their career they
don't get this right and they
uh get into a job which they do not
really want to get into
but that's the job that they got and
then they don't have an exit strategy
they'll keep on
getting more and more salary increments
and more and more uh
sort of invested into that job role and
they never come out of it
and then the their exit barrier or the
switching cost becomes too high they
just can't get out of it
and then they're stuck in a very you
know in a role that they really
don't enjoy and then that's where all
start all
bad things start happening so the fourth
most important thing before you start
your job search uh much before you you
start your job search
is the planning for what kind of role
you're doing
what role you want to do why where what
do you enjoy and this is a japanese uh
concept for ikigai which you can
actually go through look at look it up
on google
try to see you know uh where uh
where is the sweetest spot that you can
find for your career uh
dude and these ki these are a time these
are the kind of times and
when these kind of things if you've done
it uh you really make
you know you you you are in a better
place than others and also even if
you've not thought about it these are
times when you can
get the time to actually do this
thinking so i would always encourage
people to
figure this out uh where you want to
know what kind of role you want to get
into
what do you want to do in long run what
is what is professional life mean to you
oh and second is you know your job
search starts as i said
before you started job search much
before you start a job search
uh because job search when we think
about the concept it is like
you find jobs you sell jobs you apply
you send your resume you go through
interview process
but if the homework of that begins six
months nine months one year
before you actually launch your job
search so the first thing you should do
and a lot of people think you know is
this what social presence so that's the
first point
people think social presence means
creating a linkedin account
you know keeping my profile active by
keeping my profile complete
on linkedin and that is that's enough
that is better but that's a good first
step
but then that's not enough right what is
uh before his job search what you need
to do is
create some sort of uh identity for
yourself and which is not just
the run-of-the-mill linkedin account it
also means that you
are sharing whatever you're learning you
are
putting out something which is
thoughtful uh looking at your
you know field of work whatever it is if
you're a marketer
you're looking at the marketing tactics
by different companies you have some
opinion on them
similar to that if you have data science
then you're analyzing some new data
and data science script or the trends
that are coming in and you are you know
critiquing those and you putting your
perspective there
do something it's not just about
creating uh on an online presence and
then
uh you know occasionally liking update
here and update there
it's about putting something original
putting something which is valuable
and if you do that what happens is uh
with by when you share your learnings
you attract people who are looking for
people like you so you make friends
uh you attract people in your target
companies perhaps
you also attract recruiters so your
search
you know is started not by you but this
does it is actually kicked off
by a recruiter and which is what you
want to do ideally
right uh so it will make you better
people interact with people at your
dream company so if you have some
companies that you're really passionate
you're really passionate about
uh those companies you can try to
interact with them tag them
and see you know if there is some common
ground and when you
make friends with them you get some
insider information about
what those companies are working on uh
and that you can use to advantage later
on when you actually do your stock
search
so this is very important point the
problem is a lot of people don't do all
of this
and then they are left in a situation
where they have to look for jobs
all of a sudden and then since you have
nothing has been done
uh you just uh they've they spend more
and more time on application
and not really preparing their profile
uh and doing the thinking process
beforehand
so uh i would you know really urge
everyone to plan ahead or even if you're
not looking for a job
be aware of what's happening and then
work on these basic principles
i will it will help you stand out right
and that standout means
not only in terms of attracting
recruiters but also much later in the
game let's say no recruiters
contacted you but when they are when the
companies are talking to you
uh they are interviewing you or before
the offer they are trying to see
uh who you are and trying to become more
confident
you're worked out there in the social uh
space uh whether it's you know any of
the kaggle or github kind of platform
whether it is linkedin profile
any blogs that you write any websites
you maintain all of that work will be
looked
up and it will be you know at that time
you want to really stand out
and as i said earlier before you're
starting a job search not only ikigai is
important but also understanding the
growing areas where the demand supply
mode so again the same thing
find a find a place where there's more
growth
and there is a more demand and supply
if these two conditions are not there
then it is not a great place
you will have some compromises to make
and this is again you know i'm
highlighting this point because
i see a lot of people having a very
narrow mindedness
around their career they think oh and
there is a lot of literature a lot of
advice that people give to each other
and never do something for free right
something like that or but i don't
believe in that because i think a lot of
times
uh when you are trying to get into an
area where you want to walk in
you don't have any credentials to work
in that area so a lot of people i see
that they do one course in data science
and they try to get into a job with data
scientists right away
which does not really work out because
companies are looking for experienced
people in that sector
now how do you break into a sector where
people are only looking for experienced
people right
uh by doing something uh without really
expecting a return
in short term right and if you think no
i will only work
when i get paid or that advice will not
get you far because you will never get
experience
so i always say or there's an investment
that you have to make sometimes
it is for free and that investment will
give you returns in terms of learning in
terms of some work that you can show on
the resume
and a lot of people who are really good
in data science
who are learning it about it but they
don't get the opportunity they don't get
the opportunity because they don't have
experience that they can write on their
resume
if they had done something on their own
if some projects they had done if they
have helped some
if they had helped some startup and some
other work uh
they got their hands dirty and they
would have written it on it
on their resume they would have gotten
past the first stage of recruitment
filter or the screening that happens but
recruiters and they would have at least
had a shot
but today they would they don't even
have a shot because they never did
something for free
or they held themselves back from until
that point
or entering that stage so i would say
it's always important to
uh shift wherever you think you want to
shift
even if you have to work for free go
ahead and do it for some time
and you will not be disappointed
okay and this is all about your job
search preparation so what we discussed
so far
is not even job search it is about
knowing what you are good at what you
enjoy doing
what somebody will pay you for and all
of that concept
uh then figuring out where you want to
get in uh and
choosing your area to play claim
creating your presence creating your
identity
uh and uh you know even if it
getting the skills if it requires for
you to make an investment
you are not uh you know hesitating from
doing that
all of that if you do and then you enter
the job search
part of your you know of the cycle of
this process
then you are much better prepared uh
then
you have already you know you might have
already something companies
uh that you uh have on your radar
so if uh if you were doing things right
you also would have had some connections
with those
people who are working there so it would
have been easy for you to
uh tap into that network if you don't
have it it's still fine because you have
done more
you know if you had some dream companies
you were reading about them you're
reading about the work
then what you can do now is uh fix the
titan company that really want to work
at
you can go the extra mile you know do
something
special for them or look at their
business problems
try to whatever depending on whatever
you can bring to a table
try to offer a solution to them write a
cold email whatever you want to do
attract their attention
because you have spent more time on them
or you know them
you know them you know them much better
and much much from close quarters
you can actually tweak your pitch and
customize the pitch completely
so you can handle your dream companies
uh in a very
you know high touch model kind of a
basis of where you can customize
everything
for other companies apply smartly right
and a lot of people don't apply smartly
and uh what i mean is they just send a
resume
and they say you know this is uh and
this is a job i'm really interested in
the job
that's the basic opportunity because uh
application does not mean
just sending a resume application means
that you are trying to help
the recruiter or the person who is going
to look at the application
or shortlist you or map you to the job
role
that they have put out there by making
their job difficult
by writing something generic you're not
actually helping them because
you are asking them to do all the hard
work and thinking work on their own
which is not ideal like in anything
which of whatever you do in your life
you always if you are let's say uh you
know
doing if you're depending on some other
people right you always make it easy for
them to
make that decision if you're selling
something you want to make it as easy as
possible for them to buy or whatever
you're selling
but when we sell ourselves at our resume
or for a job position we don't
do that we just say okay this is a
product take it or leave it right
which is not optimal of course people
don't even read the jd's properly
i understand that jt's are not always
good also so uh
and this is where i think is one thing
is important which i would like to
highlight is
uh our job is not to blame things are as
a as when we are looking for new career
options
our job is to figure to stay positive
figure out what what is the best we can
do
a lot of jd's are not relevant a lot of
jd's are
trash uh they don't have the right uh
requirements
or they have too many requirements i
understand that happens right
but let's ignore it let's try to figure
out what is the best we can do
uh with the jd's where we want to apply
right and jd's often have the clue if
you read the jd's
you will find emphasis on certain things
and when you are applying for the role
you need to apply smartly so that those
things that are highlighted in the jd
uh they are very very easily visible in
the first
view of the recruiter and if you do that
you know that's the first level of
smartness that you can do
jd is a job description summit sorry i
could have
described it here of coming from
recruitments domain i thought jd would
be
uh you know pretty much obvious but yeah
it is not
so job description is where people
companies write uh
more about the role so if you go through
that properly you will find a lot of
clues
or companies will intentionally drop
those clues uh
and you know your job is to pick the
pick up the trail from there
oh and i think other thing after
applying for the uh for a job
is people not understanding that
a hiring process is a is actually a
process adopted by a company
uh and there are different stages in the
hiring process so it's not like every
company wants to have
know a lot of steps in the hiring
process every step
in the hiring process is there for a
reason uh
and no company wants to have more steps
in their hiring process than necessary
so if they're keeping on a step they are
focusing on something
uh in one step they might be focusing on
one kind of skills
and second step they might be focusing
on different kind of skills and third
step they are now looking at cultural
part of it right so every step
is there for a reason and every step as
a candidate
your your job becomes slightly different
from the previous step or if you
understand what is the next step
and if you can adapt your process uh and
your approach
for that step that makes it easy for you
to get past
that stuff let me kind of illustrate
that point
the first step in any hiring process is
the screening
or the basic filtering right so
recruiters have
a lot of applications uh and recruiters
are hr people
most of the time they are very young
they don't have a lot of understanding
of all the roles
that they are going to be filtering for
it's not like they're experts in that
domain right they are
they they say let's say you're applying
for data roles or applying for marketing
roles
they are not marketers themselves they
are not data scientists themselves so
what they're looking going to look at is
uh whatever they have understood from
the job description from the
hiring manager and in this case they
will uh
they will ask them to apply some room
right so it will be something like
look for two to five-year experience uh
look for
this kind of you know words or keywords
in their resume
or look for some colleges or some kind
of companies that we are you know we
have
hired from the past and stuff like that
that's the rule that they're going to
apply
right so when you are uh in the first
stage when you're applying
you your job is to get past the
recruiter and
it makes you and you have to make sure
that you know whatever the recruiters
are looking for
or that problem is solved right and i'll
talk about this in the
later part of slides as well but uh our
job at that time is to
get past the recruiter in the second
stage when introverts are involved
they are basically assessing your skills
right so anything
about your portfolio about your skills
or
where you apply the skills those things
are going to be important
at this stage uh when you are in making
to an interview round
your objective is mostly around reading
upon the past interviews or
you know knowing what the interviewers
have asked in the past
uh and or looking at what you can
highlight at that point point where to
impress them with the technical or
whatever skills of job skills that you
have
that's your job at that point a lot of
people they know that
they go to the uh third like a lot of
people you were
you might have found that they entered
the first round they cleared that second
round declared third or fourth round
also cleared
and in the fourth or fifth or sixth
round when there is some sort of bar
raiser
or some kind of a vp interview or
directory interview
or hr interview and they think oh i
don't know what happened what went wrong
what went wrong is because you took it
lightly and i am a guilty of that i'm a
person who's guilty of that
mistake as well a lot of times when we
enter the hr round we think everything
is done
uh and you know it's just a formality or
whenever we
talk to a senior uh person in the
company we think it's almost
the handshake that's going to happen but
that is not often the case
right and in that uh thing we actually
end up making mistakes
by not being now being a bit casual
about uh
and sometimes we become casual in our
approach sometimes we are not
highlighting our right things at the
right time so uh i think those
though and again at that time at that
point of the start of the hiring process
your objective changes
and you should be more cautious you
should be more
prepared about what what is so you know
great about the company
uh you should be asking some questions
as well if you just leave the
opportunity of asking great questions
uh to someone who is a director of the
company or is the founder of the company
that is an opportunity loss and it just
means that you're looking for a job
you're not really interested in joining
a company
so all those things are important but we
miss that part so
i think smart job search means
understanding
the other side of the equation knowing
that you are not alone in the universe
uh there is a process that a company has
adopted
to check something at each step of the
hiring process and at the
other end of the table there are people
who are doing their who are doing their
job
and your job is to let them do their job
properly and easily
the more difficult you make it for them
to assess them make more difficult
your resume and the your keywords and
your your
experience of your they've already told
you about gd and everything else still
you're not taking the advantage of that
that is a mistake that a lot of people
make
and uh eventually a lot of people say
that the companies
are not responding they are ghosting me
and all of those things because
a lot of times we are not optimizing our
approach
for the companies we are just doing what
we think is right but that is
you know is not right is not the optimal
approach when you're dealing with a
complex process like recruitment
so i would say have some respect and
understanding or
understand that they're also doing their
job and they also have some constraints
and our job is to you know make the job
easy as much as
possible so that is about a job search
i'm happy to take any questions about
the job search part now we are going to
go into the
ai part which is everybody's fancies
fancy these days about you know what is
ai doing and there is some sort of
misunderstanding about it
or and some also some sort of concern
around it so i'll talk about that
uh in ai and recruitment and what it
means to you as a
uh as a professional who is looking for
opportunities
uh but before that i will just stop and
see if there are any questions to it
um yeah there is a
a question here um
from dhiraj cody who asks
for a friend who is a mechanical pass
out in
m.tech mechanical engineer has been
teaching physics
has continually been working
wants to switch into a different field
as a data analyst and is curious to know
if uh
companies hire freshers people who
recently
got certifications or
qualified qualifications in new areas
like that
yeah so that is a same example i was
actually giving
uh in my section earlier a lot of people
want to enter a space
where there's heavy you know competition
and data
roles whether it's data engineering data
science
uh data analyst these are roles where
you will find a product management
for this for that matter uh these are
the fields where experience is important
a lot of people want to get into these
roles because the salary is good the
work quality is good uh
and there is a boom in these sectors so
there is more more supply and
demand also is pretty strong but supply
also is pretty strong so you are
actually fighting
a very comparative kind of a battle
that's number one
in this kind of domain and try to try to
understand this guys i mean it's mostly
about demand supply here
uh this is labor market rights and uh
the more you understand from the demand
supply perspective the better off you
would be
uh you're entering a space where there
are more people available
their jobs but the quality level of the
skill level is very high
because these jobs are typically
experiential jobs right in data science
you need to understand a lot of
algorithm a lot of mathematics and you
have to have some experience of doing
things
similarly in product management you
typically have three to five year
experience before you can actually
understand the business context that
well
or for anybody who's a fresher to enter
these spaces
it's not easy right so let's acknowledge
that that part first of all
but i'm not saying it is impossible or
in fact at cut short we have hired
someone someone who was a fresher and it
didn't find this role
and he's actually started uh you know
our data science and machine learning uh
department in that way
or he actually has already done a lot of
great work uh
as you know almost like a four-year
five-year experience person
so how does that happen right uh
companies are also lying when they say
they're not hiring freshers
right so what they're saying essentially
is we're not hiring people who need to
be taught too much
right so as somebody who's a fresher if
you are entering a space where there is
a lot of
competition your job becomes difficult
but it is possible if you have poor
skills
and more experience on your profile
and in our case for example the example
i'm giving of our own company
is that person has been working in data
science since second year or third year
of his
engineering now he already has three
years full-time experience he has worked
for two or three startups
or he has already solved a lot of
problems right so although on paper he's
a fresher
but in terms of his learning curve in
terms of his experience and the devotion
the devotion that he has shown in
through the field
is is actually speaks very you know
a very uh great picture about what his
passion is and then it becomes easy for
any company to take a bet on those
people
so i would say when you're looking for
these kind of roles uh
you just can't go to the market saying
you know what i am a fresher
i am experienced i want to get into the
data science or please give me a chance
no that does not work that way nobody is
going to give you a chance
because there's so many people who are
willing to you know who are experienced
who can do the same job
uh you have to earn it and now you and
in our case
we actually paid this person on their
terms it was not even items
right so it all depends on uh
you know the arbitrage and leverage you
have it the more skills you have
the better of it is for you so i think
as a fresher you need to build your
skills there is no other
uh alternative yes you can go to big
companies that are hiring in big numbers
but i would say still right you
kind of you get what you pay for right
similarly if you go to a company
where they don't care about your skill
set it is probably not a bad
uh the best investment of your time
right so i would say
try to get practical experience in that
freshers we can't get no i'm not saying
freshers can't get a job
get a job i asked so many companies uh
about you know whether they are they're
having freshers they say no
and what you know i change the question
next time i say do you want a great
fresher
who is skilled and they say yes right so
nobody's
saying that they're not hiring pressures
you have to create a demand for yourself
and if you have done the hard work if
you have invested your time into the
right things
or if you can show for you know yourself
about your knowledge and your
skills companies will give you a chance
and
if there is the companies who are not
giving there will be some companies that
will also be giving the chance
and there's so many companies out there
you can just uh
uh hit them up on twitter you can hit
them up on linkedin you can hit them up
on email or you know write cold email to
them
and create space for yourself but you
can't be writing a cold email saying
this is my resume please give me a job
that can't be the pitch
let's uh move on to the ai section do
you want to um
get a temperature from the audience
about how they feel about ai
yeah yeah absolutely that would be great
so a lot of people might have heard
about ai so let's ask them
about you know what is their
feeling about how ai helps them or
impacts them
okay so we have a quick call about
how do you feel about uh ai do you think
it's a as a potential candidate do you
think it's a good thing
or a uh not a good thing
for your job search
it's also showing me the question should
i answer
uh if you like
and we'll just leave it open for another
uh
15 seconds
and by the way ai is part of artificial
intelligence
yeah i didn't realize my camera was not
on
oh yeah i had uh
started my camera early on but i don't
know when it got turned off
uh it's uh i thought that was
intentional
oh no thank you for turning it on we do
want to we do like
to have people watching yeah absolutely
i think whatever face time you can get
in these times is always good
here is the result of the pull
okay that's great we have a very
knowledgeable knowledgeable crowd here
okay so
okay let me close my phone
okay great so how to deal with the ai
right so
oh it's great that you guys have already
have had
some exposure to it or you know about it
i let's let's talk about why it is good
or why it is bad right
uh so why ain't recruitment at all try
to imagine as i said earlier
it's a recruitment is a business process
where companies
are involved on the other side of a
table they have teams
and their job is to find the right
person the right job now
imagine that you know there are imagine
these numbers and these are real numbers
uh an average job attracts 250
applications per job
it's not even any exaggeration here it
can actually be 5
500 or 1000 as well uh in fact someone
told me
my team recently someone created a job
for a for a fresher
on cut shot itself and in three hours
they got 180 applications
right uh that is the kind of volume that
a recruiter has for on one job uh
average uh you know if you look at how
many jobs are open
a company a typical smaller company has
three jobs open a bigger company can
have 25 jobs open as well
right and they are they are just
application numbers
how many applications are coming at top
of the funnel then there are people who
are actively in the hiring process right
so it's a funnel
of people 250 applications per job and
three jobs are active
that means 750 people are entering the
funnel in two weeks period
and 750 people there are 50 50 60 people
who are in the hiring process
who need to be send us an assignment who
need to be doing an interview with
or the team or who need to uh be asked
more questions on a phone call
or whatever it is right whatever the
hiring process is uh unfortunately the
recruitment teams are small
now no company has infinite number of
recruiters on their
on their teams right so this is a
practical scenario
uh for any company that is hiring right
now
and with a time like this right and as i
demand supply right so try to understand
the supply side
of the candidate side of the equation
there's so many people out there
like there are millions of professionals
out there and now with
the remote friendliness and all of that
so applications are really
getting even increasing even higher
because people can now apply
to any job anywhere right so these
numbers are really rising very fast
oh and recruiting teams are small right
so
there is definitely a use case for
companies to adopt
ai or in whatever way they can so that
they can
deal with these applications these
candidates uh more efficiently and more
effectively
uh and you know it's not just about
saving time it's also about
ai being much better than a typical
recruiter
for these jobs right what you are trying
to do as a recruiter here when you have
so many applications coming in
as you're trying to figure out who's a
better fit and that better fit is
often uh it's a mathematical or a data
question right
who has worked and what kind of
companies what kind of experience they
have
how much experience they have what
skills they have worked and all that
right and as a human
it is really hard for you to look at all
the 75800 applications coming in two
weeks
uh and doing a justice to all of those
so technology is much better at these
things
uh and and that's why it is going to see
and it has seen that option that it has
seen
uh so far uh in the recruitment
uh uh process right or data needs to be
passed it needs to be understood
are there data sets that are available
uh sorry
you have uh companies or list of good
companies list of
good colleges uh what kind of uh skills
they have worked in
uh and uh other whole lot of other layer
about
you know what uh skills come under what
domain
all of that is a data data and offset
problem
and as i said earlier recruiters
generally have not been cross-functional
right a recruiter does not understand
marketing they could
not understand data science so ai comes
into that
into the picture and bridges the gap so
that the tutors don't really have to
know
all the domains uh the ai part can take
care of the relevance problem
without the recruiter really needing to
be an expert on that so that is how the
context of ai or
coming into recruitment and that's why a
lot of people you a lot of
you said it is good so it is indeed good
because it helps the other side
which is including side to look at your
resume to process your
application faster uh to become more
efficient
in finding the right person for the
right job so that's why in that spirit
it is a great move it's a great shift
right and we all love that
and where is ai being utilized the most
right so as i said matching screening
where let's say i create a job uh where
i'm looking for a specific kind of
people
uh ai can out of millions of profiles i
can find the right matches
so instead of going through all the
profiles on my own
or using some crude filters like skills
or keywords ai can find a better fitting
profile for me uh so it solves that
matching problem
or discovery of the right candidate
problem and then screening is a second
similar problem but slightly different
because now it is an application that is
coming in
oh and as i think that i want to see who
are the
out of 250 applications who are the
applications which are the applications
that are matching my requirements
and out of my people who are matching my
requirements who are the top relevant
people right that's
the second matching screening problem
and then a lot of people also
use a lot of tools also use hiring
process automation
uh and ai is also deployed there right
so
you might be getting automated messages
you might be getting reminders from an
nlp
or from a bot kind of a thing you might
be getting that you might be getting
or some video interviews also which are
assessed by ai
or itself not by humans not very often
but
uh it is something which is still
developing but people
uh also have started using it and some
other hr
problems that kind of use that companies
typically have
that is where the ai is mostly utilized
uh
and try to understand that this is not a
common ai right it's not like
one general piece that everybody's using
everybody every tool has their own
implementation of all these things
right so some tools can be very advanced
they're very sophisticated
they are more they're less error prone
and some are very primitive so our job
when we are looking for a job is to make
sure that
we are uh and every system can
understand
you know what uh how to process our
resume and how to process the
application uh the sophisticated
of course can process better but our job
is to not assume that we are only
dealing with ai system because you will
don't even know as a candidate
which ai system is being used by the
company or some company is using
something else and completing something
else right so
if that is the case then uh let's
understand that how
these ii algorithms actually work right
so before we go into
uh the the phase where we can uh
optimize for
or take advantage of ai when the
companies are using right so
most ai algorithms when they're looking
for matching screening capabilities are
looking at job titles
uh job title actually has a very uh
significant usage a lot of ai algorithms
look at the job titles
so that if you are looking there if they
are looking for applications for product
manager
anybody who has a product manager or
title already on the resume
uh will be given certain weightage by
algorithm similarly
uh they will be they'll also be looking
at job position with duration of
your work at every at every job that you
did
or it will also look at the company that
you worked at well it will also try to
figure out the companies
that what kind of companies they are are
they into
you know any specific domain or are
these services companies product
companies
and whatnot right so they'll be trying
to build some intelligence around the
companies as well
so then they will also be looking at the
key skill section uh
what and they'll try to match it this
section with
the job uh section wherever whatever was
highlighted in the job as an important
skill
does this candidate have those skills or
not and they also will be looking at
your educational history
or which institute went to which program
you did there
right so they are going to look at these
parts and
some of the ai tools also look at some
other stuff like
uh skills that you use last or any skill
when was it used last in your resume or
try to make sense out of it
uh they will also look at the kind of
work you've done not just the
the the keywords but they try to map
whether it was
data science kind of work that you did
or it was something else which you did
so they try to make sense of the
kind of work you did uh they also look
at a ten-year lens
anybody who has uh switched too many
jobs
they'll try to figure it out as well
right and there's a lot of creativity in
these tools
uh depending on what companies want to
do and what
vendors provide they they try to
implement all these features now as you
figure out
this is not accurate science right there
will be errors here there will be arrows
there
and i also said that not everybody using
one common algorithm
or everybody is using different kind of
algorithms so
since it is a cutting edge new age field
uh some companies are ahead some
companies are not ahead and every
every ai is error prone in some ways
right so if you are dealing with a
system like this
which is going to decide whether you're
going to get shortlisted or not there
can be some tips that you can use i'm
going to talk about that
uh just in a bit uh and this is the
the second part of you know how to take
advantage of that so
since your resume
in the first stage of the application is
going to be a machine
uh you need to keep these sections
whatever we saw in the previous
slide right we need to keep these
sections easy to easy to read
uh which should not make it difficult
for the algorithm to
uh understand all these sections or all
these information that they are going to
use
uh we want to make it easy for the
algorithm to pick it up
example uh is to provide the key skills
right a lot of people use non-standard
versions of the key skills right don't
use that like i use jd
in my previous slide and somebody said
what is the jd so don't take make that
mistake use the right
you know right form that is a
standardized format of any skill
uh also try to include synonyms if
you're working on skill a
and sqla also can be called you know
with name bcd
also include in bracket bcd so that
algorithm is able to
understand that that is something which
also is there on their element
and you're not getting deprived of that
opportunity just because you did not
mention this annoying
and there can be more things but don't
do the keyword stopping there uh it's
not great because the same
resume is also going to be about
recruiters later on so you don't want to
make a mistake that
all your resume is about just all the
random keywords right don't do that
but try to not like your job is here
your job here is to make sure that
whatever you have worked on
is not being missed and just because a
specific keyword is not there but you
know it
or you're not being removed by the
algorithm right that's so
there's a major focus for you here oh
customize for different kind of jobs
every time you apply for a job you use a
different resume
or if you're applying for the same
resume for marketing job as well as
product management job that will not
give you the same score right so try to
optimize your resume for the kind of
role again
objective is not to fool the aif system
by
writing something which you have not
done but if you can highlight something
differently
then sure i think that's something which
you should do oh
and you don't need a fancy resume with
charts and all of that a lot of people
try to think that you know i need
a very aesthetically defined or cool
kind of a resume which has
my you know area of expertise on the
ground for line charter bar charts and
all of that
then you know there is a different
animation something that is not required
or the more difficult to make the more
you will lose out and to illustrate that
uh let's say you are giving this giving
a set of pictures through facebook
and your objective is that facebook
should
be able to pick up people or recognize
people in the picture
right this may be your office picture
now this is picture one
do you think that this picture will be
or easy for facebook to figure out
but who who is there in the picture
right it's a valid picture
faces are clearly defined now if you
look at this
on the other hand on the other hand this
is not very
very clearly defined picture there are
no clear boundaries
and this might be a resume and the third
is what about this right it is again
something which is even more difficult
for facebook to pick up
uh now facebook might pick it up let's
say they have trained it on
even these kind of faces but a normal
site might not right so
when you're dealing with uh your resume
your job is not to become fancy this is
a great picture
but it's a fancy picture right it will
not get picked up similar to that
every phase is a section in a resume
try to make every section very easy for
the machine to understand
if something is educational criteria
educational qualification or education
history
write that don't try to put that you
know where i excelled of
my list of alma mater or something that
i don't try to
make it too creative you know you want
the machine to really understand every
part of your resume very clearly so try
to do that
try to uh don't try to test the ai
system that's not in
the no that not it's not something which
you want to do
okay now hiring process this is by the
way matching and screening and
in ai and hiring processor automation is
also used
or as i said in automating replies or
you might get reminders
you might get a bot talking to you all
those things are great
right take advantage of that because by
deploying bots by deploying these
systems
companies are automating their process
and hence they are able to
see more people and talk to more people
than they can physically do
as humans right so it's great
opportunity for you uh
but so don't ignore auto messages a lot
of people have some sort of ego issues
they think you know i am applying and
they are responding with a bot or
something i would not reply
oh don't do that because i said again
our job is not to judge
our job is to help companies do their
job right so our job is to make sure
that
if companies are trying to take
advantage of their technology
understand that they are busy they have
so many applications and let's try to
make it easy for them
so don't have you know this
bad feelings about a bots talking to you
or people automating their messages
uh don't ignore that participate in the
process uh
again but while when you're talking to a
bot don't
depend on the bots right so this is also
a great
tip for you uh that let's say you
applied you got some automated message
you provided
an information and then you stopped
right and you just waiting for the
company to come back
but try to understand that this bot also
might be working on their own and the
company might have
might not have gone through your profile
or gone through your response so if you
wait for seven days or ten days
and you're still not getting any update
you can follow up manually a lot of
people don't do that
uh this is again uh you know try if you
understand their side of the equation
they are play times when they are not
able to respond they have the intention
but they are not able to respond they
have not even seen your resume
or seen your update because of the whole
automation they are not able to
you know get on top of everything that
is happening so if you bring it up bump
it up
it's always good for you uh and try to
use across multiple channels
so if you are applying on one system and
you applied via email or replied by
email or whatever platform
uh see if you can find the emulators of
the person if you're not getting a
response there just drop them an email
or reach them out on linkedin saying
hey we were talking on that system and
uh
our conversation did not go anywhere
right i just wanted to follow up that
you know you have not missed it
it is perfectly fine and companies will
have and your your recall will happen
across multiple channels
and companies will make sure that you
know they are coming back to you
uh so those are some of the tips which i
had around
you know ai uh around dealing with ai
systems
and uh yeah i think i just have very
last slide which has some trends which i
see
uh i just wanted to enter that note but
if there are any questions then we can
take it up
we're about to get into the question and
answer session so why don't you
go ahead and conclude the slides here
and we'll go back to that okay so
nothing uh out of the world
it's something that we all know but i
just wanted to finish it up uh with
those points so basically
we talked about it uh what we are going
to see in 2021
and beyond will be that there will be
more automation right so recruitment
process for example getting automated is
one part of automation
uh content catalog or
data labeling anything which can be
automated will be automated right
so that's something that's going to
happen uh and if that's a trend
then what is the plan of action you have
to increase the job value
right you can't be doing something which
can be done by machines
oh and if it can be done by machines
they will do
it tirelessly day in and day out and you
can't beat them right so
uh if that's a trend then if you are now
in a job which can be automated then you
should really upskill yourself
you should try to figure out what is a
human value in that job and every job
has some human value
but a lot of people don't get to that
point right so even recruitment for
example
a lot of people just keep on calling
people that's an automatable job
but a lot of people a job of a recruiter
is not just to call people is to
understand people
and that can't be automated so you can
always in your own field
it's not like always everybody has to go
to this data science kind of a thing
in your field there will be a human part
and there will be an automatable part
try to focus on the in the
non-automatable part or the human part
and if that is there try to build
expertise around it and then of course
you can
get out of that thing in long run and
try to upskill and you know go to
different job functions
uh that's one thing and along with it
will come reduce job safety
uh as i said earlier for india or
you know for developed country kind of a
system or context
job safety has been so ingrained in our
in our cultural thing that we never
knew or we never thought that jobs can
be lost so easily
uh and now i think all with covet i
think a lot of people for the first time
either lost their job or they saw
someone very close losing their job so
now
it's much more a reality uh than it was
before and i think we have to accept
that
or that in you know you know in a kind
of a
modern market these things will happen
uh and the response
should be to take as early as possible
whenever you can because as i said
earlier
if you get into a role which you're not
excited about uh but you're just doing
that
because it's a safe job or you know any
safety thing
uh whenever your job looks to be safe is
actually a kind of a risky maneuver
because
it's something that is which is not
exposing you to the true
uh market dynamics and i think uh you
should try to take risk as early
a lot of people just work for five years
six years in industry and they think oh
you know i have too much investment into
one domain i can't get out no it's not
like that you have
40 50 years of career ahead of you in
long run
it doesn't really make any difference
what you were doing in the first five
years of your life
or as early as you can take the risk and
do something which
you know which can get uh you to
understand your true competencies and
build
your skills in that area uh and that
will be great
for you uh globalization of talent is
something which is happening after
covered
and this is a great opportunity for
people to find jobs anywhere
right so you the plan of action is uh if
you are already skilled
then you can take short-term benefit you
can
now you are employable and available to
a lot of companies outside india
outside your area wherever you are uh
and they can
know they can hire you reasonably and
practically for the first time in
in the entire history of mankind that's
great without leaving india you can get
employed in a company in europe
or in company and a company in canada oh
and that's great for you
but that's a short-term benefit also
understand that why you taking that
benefit
in long run that benefit will be given
to somebody else because with that
globalization whatever you whatever is
happening to you that same situation
will come to you
and or there will be somebody in africa
somebody in
you know philippines who might be
actually less
uh costly for companies to hire so in
the long term you have to prepare for it
or as i said again you have to find your
true passion
build your competencies and if you are a
top uh you know
person in your chosen field of work then
there is actually no competition you
will always been
in that competition so that is what i
had
planned now i'm i don't know if we are
i think we kind of overshot our time but
i'm happy to take any questions
okay very good um we are going to go
into a question and answer period
and um you can go ahead and do that
i'm going to ask a few questions that
came from the audience there are so many
of course that we cannot
um possibly answer all of them
um but we will give it a
go um so
uh we have a question from samir who
asks
uh he's working as an sap consultant
he's planning to do a transition into
the field of ai
um can you guide him on how to approach
his resume
and the interviewers
so first of all ai is a very broad term
or
you need to really find which stream of
which branch of ai you want to work
under
a walk-in find that uh the
within that do some projects do some
work to
build your competency around it uh and
i'm assuming that
now from the recruiter's standpoint
right so if i if i were to don the heart
of a recruiter and you apply
i'm gonna look at my job which will have
typical
requirement of three-year experience in
a specified branch of ai
and i'll look at your resume that you
want in sap and 99 times i will just say
that this person is out of it
right because uh the person is mostly
talking about sap
or it's not my job role so i would
normally not shortlist
so i i would say your job should be
to as i said earlier your job should be
to figure out the other side
and in this case your chances are not
looking bright what you should do here
here is make a resume which is not
really
very heavy on zap it is actually making
mention of sap
but it's mostly about your new found
interest in ai or your projects and ai
and your anything around that company
that you're applying to
anything specific that you cannot get
the context and instead of
writing and applying on a job portal or
to a website
try to hit the people who are on the
hiring team
or that would be my best shot in your
situation because i said earlier you are
trying to enter a space where
there is a huge competition uh people
are already available uh who are hungry
to get into it so your
you need to play the game a bit
differently applying on
a proper on normal job site on a car or
on a career page
expecting to be picked up by a recruiter
i think
that is not going to happen but it
didn't likely happen
um nepali asks
uh what when you mentioned working
across many domains what did you mean by
that
yeah so i think at any i think in most
of the professionals
life you will find yourself to have
a significant exposure to a specific
thing uh which could be a job function
it could be a specific kind of uh uh
like kind of work like in terms of
technology
or or it could be a specific domain so
let's say a
marketer working in healthcare you start
getting too much into healthcare and you
become a healthcare
kind of domain expert and which is great
but uh
before you go too deep like first three
years it's great because you're picking
up a lot of
knowledge on healthcare which is great
but after
three two from three to five or five to
eight it is not really adding a lot of
linear value to you
uh it is just increasing your risk in
that domain a bit more
uh and and you are not employable or
attracted to anybody else out
outside of healthcare so if you shift
after two years
of building competency in that specific
uh domain
you move out and get into let's say
fintech uh and also build your
apply the same rules of marketing in the
fintech domain and you pick up
more fintech understanding now you're
getting more broader in your approach
so i think there will be time when you
will be exposed to a specific thing in
your career
and there will be premium attached to it
inside the company you'll be promoted
because of that domain knowledge
and there will be more comparators who
will also try to hire you
because you have so much of already a
lot of context in that
but that is a sort of a local uh you
know maxima problem that
somebody is willing to pay you more in
short term you should try to get out and
if you diversify and broaden your base
you will be actually employable and
attracted to a bigger set of companies
so as
you know the demand supply kind of a
construction picture if you look at it
your objective as a professional is to
increase your demand
and if the more people are fighting for
you the better your your prospects are
of growth and more options you will have
to choose from right so it's always
uh in short-term versus long-term kind
of a question uh always try to
think long-term don't think about your
next healthy hike don't think about the
next job
think about the next 40 years of your
you know job right
so try to take that risk and try to
diversify it
very good um we have several questions
that relate to something you said about
a number of years of experience
versus depth of experience can you
give an example of how somebody might
emphasize in their resume the depth of
experience without going into too much
detail about years
so the funny thing is the depth of
experience shows
uh it shows in your in your thinking
process
it shows in your writing uh the more
depth you have
uh if i give you let's say
same topic and if i forget the same
topic two people or three people one is
totally a newbie
one is intermediate and one is master
you will find on the same topic they
will write things differently
right same project uh they write three
in three different ways
and the first person will write mostly
about the keywords that there was system
that we built and
like spicy intermediate will add some
more skill context about that the third
person who is a master
will not use the same language the
person will actually talk about a much
higher level
picture of the entire system or entire
solution or whatever they built
and uh that is something which is not
you can't fake it it's something which
comes with more experience and more
i get more depth you actually have more
clarity about the topic
and that in your resume shows or in any
writing in any blog or whatever it shows
so i think your depth if you have the
depth you should be able to no issue it
will show if you because your
level of understanding of that topic
will increase so
i think if you look at it if you just
look up uh
you know people's resumes so look at the
top let's say 10 15 silicon valley
uh anybody you uh idolize or you look up
to
in your domain anybody who is an expert
look at their linkedin profile
look at their resume you will find that
they're not talking about things
they're talking about ideas right and
and that is the difference between
someone who is an expert and deep and
someone who just knows the basics and
intermediate level of stuff
um richard asks um
he says he's in his first year of
digital marketing he's
got an executive position and he's a
fairly recent graduate
um but he's not a coder and
he's he thinks that coding is something
that
is a must-have these days um
is he right and when should he be
looking to
start learning that if that's something
important
yeah so i think it is always beneficial
right coding
you can i i find a lot of people who are
in marketing or other domains
who don't know about coding and
they think it's too complex or something
but and they
have you know they have less
opportunities available to them
because they kind of block themselves
out if you look at coding is just one
more level of
you know open one more branch or one
more
uh area where you can pick up uh if i
would tell you something about it
like if i say there is a new game right
or which is played in this way
you will not have any uh you know
problems understanding a new game
but when i talk about a new domain like
coding or ai or something like that
you would have a lot of blockage or a
lot of you know friction or hesitation
and
adopting it it's like same thing with
languages if i ask you
to learn german you will find it to be
very daunting task
a lot of people are polylingual they can
very easily pick up languages
uh but and when you start giving it a
shot you actually realize that you can
do it it's just that most of the times
we don't learn languages
not because of of our lack of in the
ability to learn it
it's just that we you know we don't want
to learn it and we have a lot of uh
you know we think why it is required and
we block ourselves out so i think
in case of coding also it's a great
skill uh
because not because it's a fancy thing
it's because you can make and build
something
that you want to build oh and in today's
and in future
uh uh you know years that are going to
come
uh building something is going to be a
great asset
and a great skill that you can have so i
would say remove your
clock any mental blocks you have around
coding uh don't
think it's a life changing skill or
something that
think of it as one more skill that helps
you and it's a builder skill it's a
maker skill like design
of language maths right and similar to
that coding also the builder skills so
you the more
uh building skills you have the more
valuable you will be and the more
uh liberty and more opportunities we
will have in your life so
think of that perspective and you can
learn this they are now the great thing
about
internet these days is that there's a
lot of great material available
uh which you don't really have to code a
lot of things
oh and it's very easy to understand
uh you don't need you know a lot of
maths and all of those
uh background and this there's not c
purpose we're talking about
a lot of people you started with cc
papers and they could not get far
uh today's languages are much simpler
and then a lot of frameworks that allow
you to code without really writing a lot
of code so i think it's easy for you to
pick up don't think too much about it
whoever asked this question just go
ahead and jump into it or remove any
mental blocks
i'm sure you'll be able to pick it up
and you will you know pick up one more
skill
which you can use if not used you can
work with people who use that skill
to become more productive in the team
setting so i would say go ahead and do
it don't have uh
any uh you know mental blocks around it
okay um joe asks if there's value in
video resonance
experimental value uh video resumes are
for humans to consume as of now
so we have not seen any major
uh platform using video resumes or
companies using any major platforms that
could that can do video resumes or parse
or video resumes and get the
information out of it so experimentally
yes but
nothing mainstream is there as of now so
i would say oh it is not a replacement
of a traditional resume because that's
what
uh most companies are still going to be
asking for video resume is great
once you are past the resume the main
screening stage
and you can attach it along with your
main resume so that companies who are
interested can get a more
a wider perspective into your
personality or and actually we have
hired someone very very good
also but it was a supplementary
information like a portfolio something
that you know designers have
similar to that you can also include a
video resume to make sure that companies
don't have to make a call
or set up a video call to understand you
if you have very powerful
of you have something which is really
very powerful to say to them
you can record an attachment in
attaching the resume it will work
nowadays it seems people are hiring
based on aptitude for business rather
than
skill um is that an
accurate perception or is there
really a favor of one or the other
they're hiring because of what
um he says that uh people are hiring
because of
the app uh the candidate's aptitude for
the business rather than the candidate's
skill
i don't know i really i don't really
understand the question very well but i
think both of them are important
so it's not like one versus the other uh
skills are definitely important
but you are right in long term skills
are replaceable
they are substitutable by something else
so your business
understanding of the overall business
context and problem-solving becomes more
important
so both of them are important uh it's
not uh
something which is you know replacement
of something else
and i think the last uh question it
covers
uh questions from a number of people and
it is basically
along the lines of if you have
done independent projects enough in the
new field
or um if you've
done projects as part of a program
do those count as your portfolio and are
they given weight by
employers
say it again what exactly uh on your
portfolio on your resume
um so one person's asking about
doing independent data science projects
on on his own
uh that he's posted on github does that
constitute a work sample
no it so basically it is not a replace
so it will have some weightage but here
is again the same thing right demands a
planet
so many people do the same thing they
have uh if you look at any data science
resume
most of them have done a twitter
sentiment analysis project
because of such a basic thing that all
people do right
so anything that you are doing run of
the mill is not going to give you the
edge
uh it will not be treated like an
experience for sure
uh any project you do that you do is not
an experience in itself
but any project you do is better than
not having any project right so
do that but also try to find uh
unique products or like not just a
project that you did because there was
something
it was mentioned in our you know in a
workbook or something try to come up
with
let's say prioritize that idea or
something like that make a website
or demonstrate it something unique i saw
a lot of people on linkedin for example
in a very early stages of data science
they were making these videos about
object detection right so cars are going
and
a street camera is looking at the car
and trying to identify which is
this vehicle is a car or this vehicle is
a two-wheeler
and all of that right so that's pretty
cool thing that they built and they put
it out there right so that is how
if you can do these kind of solutions
not just uh
you know showcase projects uh if you can
do a solution
and uh which is unique uh and it can be
very easily seen by people and it can be
demonstrated
do that and again as i said whenever you
are
a fresher trying to get into a field
where there's high competition
as i said your methods need to change
your methods can't be
the same old method that work for
experienced professionals which is
applying and then waiting
you have to create your chances or and
as i said most of the recruiters do the
short listing
uh your resume in this case also will
not get shortlisted most likely because
they would be the recruiters would be
would have been asked by the companies
to
look for a specific years of experience
on that domain and you would not have
that
so what you need to do is hit the
decision makers
do these cool projects uh understand the
company that is hiring pick up 15
companies that really are doing good
work and you think they you know their
founders are pretty much active or
whatever on twitter or whatever whatever
they are
and you can get their email address uh
do these projects hit them up with a
customized
uh subject line sub customize uh you
know pitch that
where you think you can bring a lot of
value attached to these three projects
where they can actually see the evidence
of your work or
what else you can do apart from the
normal one of the male kind of projects
that are there and kaggle and stuff like
that
and that is where you have a shot at
getting the interview with these people
who are decision makers
and that is a way for anybody who is not
of very you know who is trying to buck
the trend
to get into a company that they want to
get into
but very few people do it some people do
it but
some people do it but they just do the
cold emails they don't
i think in a cold email you have to get
attention or at any time
so you have to understand who you're
talking to uh people who can deviate
from the requirement are the people who
are hiring managers and founders and
directors
or hr people recruiters they can't
deviate from the trend or from the
specification because that's what they
have been told
so you have to hit the right person and
hitting the right person means you have
to
hit them by email or linkedin or
whatever it is oh and second is
you hit me and you said okay nikon i
want to work in your company is great
and work bad
but there's no evidence of your work so
this is the second requirement once you
have got my attention
you have to make sure that i am able to
understand your skills and find you to
be a very competent person
and that's for your projects that you're
talking about those can be if i can just
click on a link and see what kind of
work you have done and maybe read up
something which you have written on the
blog
that will give give me a great
confidence that this person is not just
person who is reaching out to me he's
creative
he also has the skill set and then you
just say that okay can we have a
10 bit call and that will most of the
times out of 10
you will get three or four interview
calls i think that is in general anybody
who is a fresher
uh should try to you know or could try
to use this recipe
so what you were saying something i was
just going to say that
i did have one last question
which is uh i'll phrase it this way
how does somebody um who's got
experience who's
attended interviews and not gotten
offers how do they troubleshoot their
uh their career search process
so they gone they went through the
interviews
yeah we've got uh this particular
questioner says that they lead a team of
uh
ai developers they have hands-on
experience
they've had a few job interviews and
they have not gotten
the offers they wanted um from other
companies
so what kind of troubleshooting could
this person do
so i think the best way to do it is in
the interview itself or
soon after the interview uh some people
are
they offer their feedback in the
interview itself like i offer
uh feedback if something does not go
right and
if i'm not convinced and i tend to tell
people
of what my thought process is right
that's if you find something that that's
great
or sometimes and most of the times you
will not so then you have to ask
or gauge from the experience or from the
after interview that
what exactly or is something you can
share you know
can you share some feedback whatever it
is it might be you had a great interview
or you did not have a great interview
whatever it was if you just ask for
feedback
at the end of the interview that would
also uh help you understand the thought
process at that moment itself
if you leave that opportunity and don't
ask there oh and then
uh they say okay i'll get back to you or
something like that and then you write
to them with a follow-up message and
then you ask for feedback
i found that to be psychologically
getting more difficult for the person to
give
feedback because the person said they
would get back they did not get back
you followed up they did they ignored or
they did not reply
or they did not they were middle or
something they could not know remember
all the details and all of that
so i would say uh try to keep it as
close to the point of interview as
possible
and after as soon as interviews over
just ask them explicitly that can i ask
you a question if you don't mind
or it would be great if you can give me
feedback on what a thought process
is uh what i you know what i did
or what where i could improve or what do
you think is
the fitment going to be looking like or
whatever it is and then i think
uh if you solicit some feedback there
you will get some more data points i
think that would be my only thought
process at this point i'll think more
about it
i don't know what else you could do
because i understand that if you do it
later
i don't see that to be working out most
of the times because
people will have so many follow-ups
emails and all of that and they would
not have time to
really give you a very structured
feedback at that time
that makes sense so with that our
questions and answers are done
i will want to um
say thank you can you give
people a way to get in touch with you
through linkedin
um and this has been a wonderful session
i really appreciate your
your candidness and and your
uh in-depth insights so
okay i'm glad go ahead yeah thanks for
inviting me
and uh this is my favorite topic guys so
you know you can ask your questions
after on uh correcting on linkedin
uh and we could do something like this
again uh i as i said
oh in cut shot basically it's a
recruiting platform but the whole idea
of
cut short is to bridge the gap
between the people who are passionate
who want to do something in their career
or connect with the company that are
looking for you and solve those problems
one by one
so there is a great investment the
company has and
i personally have in the this entire
space of making professionals more
successful
so it's my favorite topic so i would
love to help
you know more in any time personally or
in any of these sessions again in the
future
thank you again um i want to mention
that
simple learn has launched a program
called skill
up which gives people free access
um to many of our basic
courses across a whole variety of
digital
uh and digital related technologies
um i've put the link in the
chat and you'll be able to follow it
from there
and i do encourage people to check that
out
as i said it's free no obligation and
gives you access to
our basic in introductory courses so
uh we will have another in our series of
webinars
next tuesday same time 9 p.m india
um digital transformation in the post
covered world
of tech mahindra
she's the chief transformation officer
and so she's uh an expert on
how digital transformation is changing
careers for tech professionals
hope you all join us then and
you can connect with us on our various
social channels
facebook twitter linkedin
so please do and we look forward
to having you at future webinars and we
hope
that we will be able to have a crunch
back
in one of those so thanks again to
everybody
and this is the end of our our webinar
if you log off of webex at this time
please answer the survey
it will appear in your web browser and
we look forward to seeing you next week
yeah and give us feedback and uh on
linkedin also you can give me feedback
or if you have any follow-up questions
or if you have any
improvement areas for me i'd love to
hear from you thank you
bye have a good night
you